[Music]
something else i've changed my mind on
yeah i'm way way way more bullish on
sauna than i have ever been before i
used to be
in the camp of sauna feels great
it maybe even helps you sleep a bit
better
um that's probably about it like there's
no way you're going to really live
longer because you're in a sauna
and while truthfully we don't have
really great prospective data
or sorry i should say we have good
prospective data we don't have good
randomized data
i think this is one of those things
where the burden
of evidence in the non-randomized data
is
so strong it's becoming hard to ignore
so most of the research on this subject
has come out of finland
and the lobbyists yeah um
and so there's the obvious issues with
this right the people who can afford
dasana
are by definition going to have more
time on their hands more disposable
income
probably more education like all of the
standard
uh things on top of that if you're going
to choose to sauna because you believe
it's healthy what else are you doing
because you believe it is healthy i mean
right so so you know if if the data
showed that
sauna versus non-sauna was like a 5
improvement in mortality it would be
hard to get that excited about it
but when you look at the largest
published series on this
you see a benefit in all cause mortality
a relative absolute permanent a relative
risk reduction of 40 percent
and an absolute risk reduction of like
18
those are those are high numbers those
are ridiculous numbers
and that's when you um are comparing
someone who owns like saunas four to
seven times a week
i was gonna ask yeah so what's the dose
in frequency what's the yeah yeah what's
the discrepancy and what do you believe
the minimum effective dose to be kind of
like the zone two training you described
what it is
and then you said that yeah three hours
just to get to the punch line i i think
based on the research the med
is four sessions 20 minutes
80 degrees celsius four sessions
times 20 minutes 80 degrees celsius
yep oh you fahrenheit what's the
conversion there i should have
that's about 175 fahrenheit 175
fahrenheit
got it dry wet
there's much more literature on dry you
know i actually had a call with a
patient this morning and this topic of
saunas came up
and she asked if she could substitute
steam rooms and such
and i said we just don't know because we
don't have the data um
so the you know the precautionary
principle would say if you have access
to a dry sauna
that's where we have reams and reams and
reams of data
so it's probably where it goes but look
if you think about what the mechanism of
action is yeah i was going to ask you
next is it heat shock proteins is it
something else i think it's many things
i think it's heat shock proteins i think
that's nitric oxide i think it's like
literally vascular tone
right reduction in blood pressure uh
it's an it's like you know increase in
heart rate and cardiac output so there's
a bit of an exercise
benefit um i don't know if bdnf i think
bdnf has been measured i can't recall
that could be another
uh potential benefit so my guess is bdnf
brain derived neurotransmitter perfect
factor
yeah i think it's probably half a dozen
things that are all moving in the right
direction
um it's funny when i have done some
sauna ing
i've done lactate checks in there to see
if it gets me to la
zone two it's not so it's not a pure
exercise memetic because it doesn't even
get me to the level of a zone two
workout
um at least when it comes to a pure you
know
adp atp uptake or atp production
standpoint
but yeah i've become like really
optimistic on this and i think it's uh i
think it's very promising
and i think it's again it's the
challenge is how scalable is it right
like it's not
as it's not that easy to do i would
imagine also contraindicated for a lot
of folks
yeah yeah i suspect you know if you're
if you're really far down the line of
your health is is suffering and you're
you know particularly old or something
like that
or your heart's a little more frail yeah
this would this might push you a little
bit beyond so again it speaks to sort of
prevention and
and hopefully with covid kind of winding
its way down and enough people getting
vaccinated people can get back to gyms
where saunas are and things like that
yeah amazing
you